[Music]
how many of you guys
participated in extracurricular
activities when you were kids
my whole life marching band
marching band nerd standard no but then
i was also on pep
what did you do for the uh marching band
what what instrument yeah
what did you play uh clarinet is that
the straight one
yes the black straight one right and i
also was in this like film club
thingamabob where we like
worked backstage for musicals you know
like like you set everything up
that's cool i also like tried out for a
bunch of stuff that i didn't get
with no experience that's not on er
that's pretty cool i was just like
i just never feared uh rejection
i ran for class president like didn't
make it i ran for a class
treasure i didn't make it yeah i didn't
make [ __ ] i didn't even have trouble
i did i know they they play all the
money
no i don't but i just freaking tried out
for it basketball
you just show up with no show up
expectations nor
experience that's honestly the energy i
still keep today and like it's just like
why not how do you know you're not
capable until you do it
and of course so you know i joined this
one like all boys club at school
and like they beat me up as a team to
get in
and then we did a lot of things that
weren't really jumped in
yeah i don't know it was i don't know if
they're extensioned by the school or was
this just like
nothing was independent you're so cute
dude that you're asking this
yeah did you have uniforms uh we had
colors
that we wore yeah uniforms it was cool
that's cool
didn't hear it so i couldn't chime in
you asked the question
i know you did it you didn't no you
didn't he volunteered the information
she answered the question and then zoned
out
oh i'm asking because uh a recent poll
suggested that teenagers who spend less
time in front of screens and more time
doing extracurricular activities
uh have better mental absolutely well
[ __ ] i'm not a teenager anymore
does it work now yeah and i'm i was
about to say it works for
all of us you spend too much time on the
screen sherry
that one the sick hour a day oh right
how many hours do you scream let me see
how do i check i'll tell you right now
go on swipe all the way left and then go
to screen time you don't need to get off
here what color is it
today i already have four hours and 53
where is it today i'm two hours and 50
minutes [ __ ] i'm still trying to find it
how do i get i don't know how do you do
it we have the same
three hours how do you get there oh no
no i didn't read these categories four
hours and seven minutes
what's your daily average oh it's that
wasn't even on who spends the least
amount of time that would be the winner
today well today we're busy here so
we're not spending as much time as we
usually spend
oh i see three hours and 28 minutes
daily average
i've been using my phone a lot more
these days but there was a a good chunk
of period of time during the quarantine
that i almost never touched my phone
six hours i'm four hours i'm five hours
today
oh [ __ ] wow oh yeah you weren't here
this morning i wasn't here this morning
i woke up like freaking i had a combat
test at 6 30 a.m two hours
two hours i've been uploading for the
week 4 20. dude is my phone bro for the
week
that's 26 minutes you guys are in the
hours i'm like
oh you almost never touch your phone too
wait how do you find the weak one
oh oh yeah it's like you got dates two
hours and 37 minutes a day
oh my god i'm nervous about the week oh
wait today is 28 hours
no it's week average it's that's your
average oh no that's my daily average is
eight
hours tuesday the most which was
election
makes sense i'm on instagram for 25
hours
oh a week i don't have anything i'm
still really confused to be honest
oh [ __ ] me up total screen time 52 hours
in 16 minutes
damn i collected this week my i don't
know
i'm not sure 26 hours don't talk about
little screen time 40 hours this week
wow crazy we're pretty cool with this
huh i mean i don't it's almost like
eight years is blessed
um it was off so it says zero oh haha
oh your phone was off this whole time no
i don't think i think when it updated it
didn't
like right oh it's just a zero click
it also breaks down what you're using
too like what kind of apps and stuff
just uh yes and how insecure you are so
what's the story
right so basically what the researchers
found
is that teens and i would say this is
this expands past
teenagers well how happened he put the
sword into the mouth he just has a d
i don't know i think it was just the
reflex or something he just
i get tense it was like
yeah like a shake weight like a shake
weight
you guys weren't sorted between your
legs like that
oh that's what he did out of nowhere
he's playing the clarinet oh [ __ ] you
guys don't do that sometimes where you
just have
like tense parts where you just need to
shake it out like oh yeah for sure yeah
i i did when i was a child and i had
like very very crazy adhd
right i used to do something i used to
do some stuff i like to scream
from time to time i never heard you
scream oh screaming
what do you do when you do it about it
oh that was a good stroke
only when i'm frustrated though only to
blow off some steam not for no reason i
should do that often because it's
like roller coasters i miss so much and
that's that's
that was my screen therapy right oh
those roller coasters i just pinched my
nipples really hard
yeah these are actually good like i
guess extra correct maybe they're not
extracurricular but like
i think these are great things to do
during times of
covid and pandemic so basically what
researchers found was that teenagers who
reported more than
two hours of recreational screen time
per day had lower levels of life
satisfaction
optimism and higher levels of anxiety
and depressive
symptoms and i would say that extends to
adults too and i feel like [ __ ]
especially during pandemic times we've
been does it matter
what you do on the screen um what if
you're reading
out here trying to look for loopholes
like i got a [ __ ] happy crossing time
animal crossing that makes me happy as
[ __ ] that's true that's just my stress
really
not anymore it's been so long what if
i'm working online on my phone
it must be a social media what if it's
like sudoku
no because i'm thinking about like isaac
for example he spends a lot of time
in front of his pc but he's playing
video games the whole time
when you see no no he leaves his door
wide open
that must make him happy i don't know
what is he 12
12 i was doing that [ __ ] 48 hours
non-stop
yeah and i was happy i would just take a
break to go pee grab some food and i'll
be eating my [ __ ] cup of noodles
while i'm playing games
non-stop it's a part of childhood it's
normal but
it is different times
it is different times with video games
because now it's
all like online interaction too it's not
necessarily just only solo play no there
was online interaction back then like
you play world of warcraft
you can play all kinds of other games
counter strike
you know well i think just being locked
up in a room
by yourself isn't it takes breaks though
when you're bored in the house in the
house
well because back in the day like well i
didn't really i'm trying to think of
what i did back in the day i didn't
really when i was 12 what did you do
when you were talking did you
i was in my room locked up we had the
internet then
i did i did we were just on tv all day
oh aim oh right that was that was a i am
yeah i would chat a lot
right play games a lot i would watch
cable tv all day every day for like
my almost my whole life we felt pretty
good we didn't spend like 30 minutes
loading a porn picture
oh dude those were the [ __ ] days man
poor picture not even videos yeah this
is you know what i'm talking about look
at this
so and then you're just like standing
there with your dick just ready to go
what did y'all why didn't y'all do like
magazines you didn't start jacking off
to
whichever body part it was stuck on it's
like the earlobe no i'm like stroking it
but then i got to the earlobe and then
the
like you're necklace it right yeah
you're like you're like the train is
starting to move
and then until it's like incomplete you
don't really start
going furiously at it true well i i even
i
imagine like floating up it's also like
undressing the girl you know
so you slowly yeah but you're just kind
of like you're you're caressing yourself
and then once it's done you're like
yeah and then boom he's like you know
yeah it's like you threw the hat at the
[Laughter]
wait what would you do would you get so
[ __ ] up if like you were prepping your
peen
and then like it was loading and then it
turned out to be one of those remember
those like videos of the car going
through the field and all of a sudden it
would be like this scary face
i hated them thank god they were
pictures now that would have loaded slow
too the guy would have came in scary
like
wait what was rick roll again that's so
familiar so you're watching a video and
then in the middle of the video goes
to leave you now goodbye
you're such a broadway performer right
now with your hat and
that makes me feel like it's crazy
because
we only needed one picture for a
full jack session now it's like a
picture
you need multiple tabs yeah you need
like four videos
yeah it's always tabs yeah i do more
than one you don't just watch one
that's a problem i mean even on our
phones i feel like i talk right between
like apps and like instagram my
instagram's boring yeah twitter twitter
right
facebook you know it's like because
we're spoiled we're we have too many
options
i blame yogurtland too many basket
robins
they started it off but you cannot do
that but you cannot do this
do you like coconut i do love it i love
it get
flakes are like pineapple and coconut
and make your own pina colada yes
tart oh no wait are we talking about
robins or yogurtland no like ice cream
i don't think they have that i don't
know no no ice cream like
get a scoop of coconut get a scoop of
pineapple they sell pineapple coconut
make your own
no i don't want a pina colada i want to
make my own no they call it no like uh
which one's the brand that well
they make it for you is it briars or
dryers i always get them mixed up briars
i know why would they do that
why would you do that who do you think
came first
dryers taste like [ __ ] i think b briars
because it's like
alphabetically first and then briars is
is bomb it's creamier
criers didn't work priors didn't work
all right dryers found in 1928
breyers 1860. i told you breyer's was
the og oh [ __ ]
we got briars which one is the better
one briars i don't know are they the
more expensive ones yes
you know what probably happened is it
was the same people same company and
then one of them did the no but
there's did the spin off and it wasn't
as good yeah it wasn't they failed
i can't taste it they probably still
made a hell of money yeah i really like
thrifty to be honest the rite aid ice
cream
oh yeah chocolate crunch black cherry
bro
black cherry b.c
you know what we used to do we are so
trashed that we would be like let's meet
up
and go to thrifty's right now and grab
it and then we would go and
just just to get that wait what is that
i was definitely doing that often
i still do it your friends and you only
met that was like a play date for me
though like hanging out at the parking
lot and we got the cylindrical
[ __ ] shaped cones and we're just
licking that with the two holes
the [ __ ] yes with a snake bite
yeah i know we're out here like licking
cones right
they look like that
why did i not change the shape i wanted
the [ __ ] i wanted that gun
so bad they just smashed it they're just
walking down the street without getting
lucky
and all right we're like and we're in
the parking lot just with our cars
parked and it's like
just talking about life and [ __ ] from
writing
talking [ __ ] about somebody while you're
[ __ ] eating a thrifty ice cream
oh my goodness it's like a good old days
oh and sometimes i wouldn't i wouldn't
get the cone i would get the cup it
would just be like the two
you know it looked like the shake weight
yeah
it looked like itself oh my goodness
it's too much
you